[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
lieu qui accueillera la finale du
tremplin des voix voici le sommaire ils
sont 18 chanteurs encore en lice la
finale du tremplin des voix se déroulera
samedi 5 février à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
c'est la septième édition de ce concours
de chant ouvert à tous on en parle avec
le présentateur de ce rendez vous le
trio jazz ses manies dévoile son premier
album intitulé du même nom il présente
aussi le clip de la chanson she really
well and power et enfin du 2 au 15
février c'est la 32e édition du festival
ciné junior de 6,17 à elancourt
participent à l'événement
[Musique]
c'est benneteau
je me trouve dans la salle de spectacle
de la maison de l'environnement à magny
les hameaux la finale du concours de
chant du tremplin des voix se déroulera
samedi 5 février ici même dix-huit
candidats sont en lice enzo voix jean
bonjour bonjour cela vous êtes le
responsable communication et
présentateur dieu concours alors c'est
la septième édition du tremplin des voix
l'année dernière vous aviez fait ce
format numérique j'imagine que vous êtes
heureux de retrouver le public cette
année on est très heureux de retrouver
le public cette année on est très
heureux babolat de pouvoir leur proposer
un spectacle aussi exceptionnel que
l'année dernière mais tout simplement
avec eux en face et c'est vrai que ça
nous avait manqué beaucoup l'année
dernière de voir des réactions d'avoir
les applaudissements et même pour les
candidats c'est assez difficile de faire
une prestation sans avoir de réaction du
public c'est pour ça que cette année on
a eu la chance pas que sur la finale
mais aussi sur les autres étapes
précédant la finale vient de retrouver
ce lien que public qui nous avait tant
manqué et pour ceux qui le connaissent
pas le concours elle c'est la septième
saison est-ce que vous pouvez nous le
présenter sur
le tremplin des voix c'est un concours
de chant ou des candidats son centre de
metz affronte dans trois catégories
différentes interprète 17 ans et moins
interprète 18 ans et plus et auteur
compositeur interprète et justement
peut-être le but est de mettre en
lumière ces jeunes talents finalement
sont pas connues c'est ça notre but
c'est vraiment de les mettre en lumière
qu'ils aillent aussi une première
expérience scénique ou alors une
expérience scénique unique en tout cas
parce que maintenant c'est plus qu'une
expérience scénique c'est une expérience
aussi télévisuel c'est qu'ils vont être
filmés ils vont être retransmis aussi un
peu jean peut lire partout dans le monde
sur youtube à la réunion on serait de la
réunion via une chaîne locale évidemment
sur tv soixante dix huit pour tous tous
les héninois et même l'île de france
mais voilà c'est une expérience unique
qui vont vivre une expérience
extrêmement humaine on est là vraiment
pour leur apporter de l'expérience on
bat les coachs et on va être extrêmement
précis avec eux et on va vraiment les
aider c'est parce que les candidats sont
pas juste des numéros qu'on doit faire
passer on passe vraiment du temps pour
les coaches et scéniquement vocalement
techniquement pour vous dire on a même
des partenariats ma soeur pour pouvoir
les détendre juste avant un spectacle
non vraiment nos candidats
tout et en même temps simple c'est
normal parce que c'est eux la la source
du spectacle la source d'émotions qui va
nous faire avoir la larme à l'oeil et
j'espère alors ce concours il est ouvert
à tous quelles sont les conditions pour
participer finalement à des conditions
j'ai un peu envie de dire si vous
chantez vous pouvez venir alors en fait
les conditions comme j'ai dit voilà
c'est on va dire c'est de 9 à 99 ans
donc on a vraiment des artistes qui vont
être qu'ils vont toucher un public
extrêmement large qui sont tous très
différents cette année on a reçu à peu
près une deux cents 200 250 inscriptions
alors justement à paraître cette finale
alors ils sont 18 candidats en lice et y
at il des yvelinois à bâle or c'est ce
qu'on va regarder tout de suite alors
sur ses candidats nous avons quatre
églises mois donc qui vont venir du
mesnil saint denis
vernouillet rossi de bruel en vexin et
aussi de son charme voilà qui est un
petit peu plus loin dans les yvelines
mais voilà c'est c'est quand même c'est
quand même un petit peu dit viennois qui
participent au concours la majorité des
candidats depuis une semaine on voit la
soie des yvelines soit d'ile-de-france
20 ans quand on voit un peu plus large
et après on avait comme des candidats
qui vont venir d'un peu toute la france
est évidemment quatre candidats aussi
qui vont venir de l'île de la réunion
qui ont remporté les étapes précédentes
sur sur le territoire voilà donc on a
quand même des candidats qui viennent
d'un peu partout et les avantages de ça
c'est qu'on va tomber sur des styles qui
sont terriblement différent et ça va
être vraiment bien pour pour l'
équilibre du goncourt alors on va parler
peut-être de cette soirée aussi comment
ça va se dérouler alors cette finale
samedi vaincus rire alors la finale
c'est un petit peu particulier
ça va être une très grande soirée qui va
en fait démarré à 17h pour le public et
en fait on va tourner cette finale de
17h à
19h30 à peu près et en fait le public ne
sera pas les résultats en tout cas le
public de la salle ne sera pas les
résultats jusqu'à la fin de la diffusion
parce qu'en fait on tombe du coup de 17h
à 19h30 et après dès 19h on diffuse le
spectacle sur youtube télé kréol et tv
78 voilà donc vos spectateurs de votre
antenne pour ont bien apprécié le ton
plein des lois et en fait on va devoir
attendre que bien le public en ligne
fasse aussi ses choix prennent des
décisions pour avoir les résultats et du
coup les résultats seront annoncés en
fin de diffusion vers 21h plusieurs prix
sont attribués et les gagnants j'ai vu
où pourront bénéficier d'un suivi
personnalisé sur l'année des séances de
coaching est aussi plein d'autres
avantages c'est ça on a par exemple des
stages aleikoum que l'académie
internationale de comédie musicale on va
avoir aussi des producteurs qui vont
directement bas prendre ces artistes là
et
coach est encore plus long que le
concours ça va aller leur faire faire
des maquettes faire des projets
enregistrait des cover aussi avec des
vrais moyens de
production en fait merci beaucoup c'est
le voisin d'avoir été notre invité est
on le rappelle samedi 5 février à ne pas
oublier à 17 heures du coup pour les
participants ceux qui souhaitent venir
pour le public et puis à 19 heures à
partir de 19h soixante et soixante dix
huit voilà merci beaucoup m de ventes
merci toujours en musique le trio essaye
manioc des voileux son premier album du
même nom trois musiciens aux
inspirations en jazz qui viennent de
maurepas et versailles il nous présente
aussi à leurs clips cheese anywhere elle
aurait regardé je m'appelle manosque y
est je suis le bassiste du trio selmani
je m'appelle en tuyaux fermo et vidéo je
suis le guitariste de ses manies
je suis yann garot je suis le batteur du
trio jazz slimani
issus des trois générations différentes
ces musiciens composent le trio selmani
depuis 2015 propres aux inspirations
rock folk jazz ou encore blues dévoile
son premier album atterri comme leur
taille mais
chacun peut se retrouver dans la musique
que j'écris et n'est pas spécifique
vraiment à un mouvement mais à
des multi mouvement je dirais requis qui
permettent justement une ouverture sur
n'importe quel public n'apporte que
souvent on dit au dessus du jazz donc
que je n'aime pas voilà c'est l'idée que
se font les gens et donc j'essaye année
c'est avec notre musique de laon montrer
que bach de jazz c'est pas que ça
pas de chanteur dans ce groupe seul la
musique prime mais pour autant les
mélodies rap toujours une histoire que
ce soit 6 et noir que ce soit strates
que ce soit l'élégance de l'arbre aussi
et milo c'est des choses qui partent
d'une idée d'une idée d'un principe goût
d'une histoire c'est beaucoup des
sensations j'ai pas là on rejoint le
côté un peu je pense charnelle de la
musique quoi c'est ce que ça nous évoque
et après moi je trouve ça aussi
intéressant d'avoir un immense pour ça
qu'on a décidé de le mettre dans le
niveau d'avoir la clé de lecture et de
pouvoir après leur écoute et en pensant
à lui est d'accord on fait emilio penser
aux aux migrants par exemple en écrivant
ce morceau et ça donne un peu un jour
nouveau morceau quand on écoute venue de
maurepas et de versailles ces trois
musiciens ont sorti un clip le 18
janvier de la chanson she's my way and
wear
2 on
on a fait ce clip à maurepas
donc à côté du bassin de la courance
dans une belle campagne là bas
de triomphe by many se produira mardi
1er février au sunset sunside à paris
ils seront également en concert à
maurepas le vendredi 9 décembre
[Musique]
parlons un cinéma à présent du 2 au 15
février c'est la 32e édition du festival
ciné junior
un rendez vous incontournable
d'éducation à l'image pour les enfants
cette année il s'installera dans trois
villes à magny les hameaux les
clayes-sous-bois ou encore elancourt
c'est un festival qui existe depuis je
dirais une quinzaine d'années en val de
marne et qui sait les exporter hors les
murs depuis nous on le fait depuis cinq
ans de mémoire
donc c'est un gros festival qui est
vraiment dédié au jeune public avec
beaucoup de films de programmation
spécifique et puis beaucoup d'ateliers
nous tous les ans on essaie de faire des
ateliers on passe the kid de charlie
chaplin donc à voir ou à revoir avec les
enfants et puis on aura ensuite une
petite animation
pour se mettre à la place du caméraman
du preneur de son espèce de petit jeu de
rôle avec des cartes ou des participants
viennent de refaire une scène du film
jusqu'au 6 février la biennale de danse
sur quel pied danser propose des
représentations de spectacles ou des
actions culturelles sur 15 villes de la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise hip hop modern jazz ou encore
contemporain tous les styles sont
représentés vendredi 4 février au
théâtre simone signoret à conflans
sainte honorine la compagnie par terre
présente à mon bel amour un spectacle
qui mélange danse hip hop contemporaine
et classique à l'aqualud vert marine à
mantes la jolie le spectacle la mémoire
de l'eau par la compagnie pernette est à
découvrir samedi 5 février
représentation originale de la danse
contemporaine aquatique
et si vous alliez à la rencontre des
animaux du roi c'est le nom de
l'exposition automne 2021 au château de
versailles il ne vous reste plus que 13
jours pour venir découvrir pas moins de
300 oeuvres toutes ont un lien avec les
animaux qui ont vécu dans la bâtisse
royal
voici l'animal préféré du roi louis xiv
la poule sultane un animal domestique
présent au château de versailles une des
nombreuses curiosités à découvrir durant
l'exposition les animaux du roi du 12
octobre au 13 février 2022 toute la
faune présente au coeur de la cité
royale sur différentes générations de
louis xiv louis saez en passant par
louis 15 on sent qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose d'assez important dans la
conception des animaux de leur personne
le respect l'attachement aux animaux
véritable arche de noé version ancien
régime cette exposition propose 300
oeuvres une rencontre avec les animaux
qui ont participé à la vie du château de
versailles à commencer par cette
éléphante naturalisés de louis 15 une
réalité de l'époque à la ménagerie
royale construite entre 1662 et 1664
aujourd'hui détruite l'idée de du roi
c'était d'avoir une ménagerie qui
montrerait toutes les espèces les plus
curieuses de la terre on avait
évidemment les animaux les plus
extravagants ours enfin tout ce qu'on
pouvait réunir dans la ménagerie était
présent et il ya eu des scènes fameuse
de dissection d'études de ces animaux
puisque le l'esprit était très
scientifique pendant tout l'ancien
régime le lien avec l'animal c'est aussi
lors d'une activité traditionnelle du
roi la chasse à courre
[Musique]
la façon de gérer les mails émeutes et
les chiens de chasse que ce soit de la
chasse à tir où la chasse à courre est
par exemple le fait de donner des noms à
tous les chiens de chasse qui est une
nouveauté sous louis 15 en fait on ne
les voit pas comme de simples outils qui
servent à poursuivre le gibier ce sont
des compagnons en fait d'un exercice de
ce loisir royal à plumes ou à poils les
animaux sont aussi des symboles
politiques
un moyen pour le roi de représenter son
pouvoir absolu
et c'est la fin de cette ut culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel illinois bonne soirée sûreté de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]